the idea of hiring
a uh kind of a french electronic
duo to do a major motion picture score
at the time was um concerning
and required a lot of conversations
on tron um but uh
they quickly proved that they um were up
to the task
and um and and did a great job so
uh what do you think convince them
because it's like
did they say we need orchestral type
score and you say well they can do that
too
how did you convince them yeah well it
started it just started with a
conversation between me and and daft
punk about
what we want to do and we we very
quickly learned that we both wanted a
hybrid score of electronics and
orchestra and
you know i've been listening to their
music for 10 or 15 years at that point
and knew
that their musicality went much deeper
than
you know kind of just your standard
electronic music
um but yeah we went to disney and and we
agreed to they agreed to meet every big
composer in
in la and essentially we were going to
do it as a
partnership between them and on zimmer
or them and alexander display so they
went and met
everybody and after they had done all
their meetings around town
they said you know what we think we
think we can do it
on our own um with an orchestrator
um so uh they did a couple of demos
um and uh and disney
uh you know said all right let's give it
a shot and um
and we you know we started very early i
mean the music for that film was written
while we were shooting so i was able to
play it on set while we were shooting
the movie which was a very cool thing
that i haven't been able to do since
um but uh it was it it was it was always
there and around us while we were making
the movie which is really cool
first of all if anyone has not heard the
tron legacy soundtrack
it's one of my all-time favorite
soundtracks it's brilliant
it's amazing and all of you need to own
it but
i just want to start with that but joe
i believe and i could be wrong about
this but didn't daft punk give you a
bunch of music
and some of it did not end up in the
movie so is it true or false that you
still have
unreleased staff punk music that might
have been in tron legacy
i would never neither confirm nor deny
that there may be
some incredible music um that wasn't
uh we weren't able to fit in the movie
um but
uh but yeah someday it would be nice to
um
to figure out some way to to share that
i i can't believe with the success of
that soundtrack that disney maybe
someone that disney doesn't realize you
guys could put out an extended
soundtrack
featuring unreleased just brainstorming
here yeah
yeah disney needs disney needs some uh
other
uh revenue streams right now they're
they uh
i'm i wouldn't be surprised if if if we
decide to do that at some point i think
it'd be great